[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing the
Ministry of Magic or more specifically
the Minister of Magic who oversees all
of the operations of the ministry the
Ministry of Magic is of course the
primary form of government in the
magical world at least in the UK we do
know that other countries have a similar
structure that they may be named
differently like a muggle government the
ministry's responsibilities are vast and
are massively important in sustaining
law and order in the magical world there
are many different departments inside of
the ministry including the Department of
Magical Law Enforcement the Department
of Magical accidents and catastrophes
the Department for the regulation and
control of magical creatures the
Department of International magical
cooperation the Department of Magical
transportation the Department of Magical
games and sports and the Department of
mysteries the Minister for magic is of
course the primary leader of the
Ministry of Magic this is the highest
rank possible inside of the ministry and
is comparable to the Prime Minister or
president of a country one massive
responsibility of the Minister of Magic
is to meet with the muggle Prime
Minister were necessary one interesting
fact that I never knew is the muggle
Prime Minister has a magical portrait of
EULA Camp the First Minister in his
office in number 10 Downing Street if
there is an emergency and the Minister
for magic needs to meet the muggle Prime
Minister the Prime Minister is alerted
via yulik so the Minister for magic has
a lot of responsibilities and it's a
very prestigious position which makes me
wonder how are they elected
I don't recall the books or films
referencing this much so I did a bit of
digging it turns out that the magical
government follows democracy and that
the minister is democratically elected
this means that the public gets a say in
who makes the shots in the Wizarding
World however it's also worth mentioning
that in times of crisis their standard
Democratic format goes out the window a
little bit if you didn't know already
Dumbledore has been asked to take the
reins as Minister for magic multiple
times
but each time he's refused as he's
condemned with his post as headmaster of
Hogwarts what's also interesting is that
unlike most muggle governments there is
no limit to ministers term with that
being said there is a requirement for
them to hold elections as a maximum
interval of every 7 years it is not
uncommon for a Minister for magic to
hold his post for a substantial amount
of time relative to muggle government
standards so you probably already know
about a few of the ministers but I doubt
you know about all of them the Ministry
of Magic was formed in 1707 so as you
can imagine there have been quite a few
phases starting at the beginning here
are all of the ministers for magic
number one
yulik camp yulik camp was the original
Minister for magic he was in office from
1707 to seventeen 18 and he spearheaded
the transition from Wizards Council
which preceded the ministry to the
ministry he was previously head of the
wizened gamut and he is famous for
founding the Department of Magical Law
Enforcement number two Damocles
rowl demo coals Rowell was the second
Minister for magic and had served from
1718 to 1726 Raoul was known to be tough
on muggles and this was a big part of
his election campaign
he was eventually censured by the
International Confederation of wizards
and was eventually forced to step down
number three Perseus Parkinson Perseus
Parkinson was the third Minister for
magic and he served from 1726 to 1733
Parkinson attempted to pass a bill that
would make it illegal for wizards and
witches to marry muggles
this was unpopular with the Wizarding
community and he was voted out eldritch
Diggory eldritch was the fourth Minister
for magic and he served from 1733 to
1747 he was famous for establishing an
aura recruitment program he was never
voted out but tragically died in office
from dragon pox number five
Albert boot Albert boot was the fifth
Minister for magic and he served from
1747 - 17 to1 and community very
likeable but also not very capable he
resigned after he poorly managed
Copland rebellion number six basil flack
basil was the sixth Minister for magic
and he only served a term of two months
he resigned after the rebellious goblins
joined forces with werewolves it was too
much for basil to handle number seven FS
to score Hephaestus Gor was the seventh
Minister for magic and served for 18
years from 1750 to to 1770 he is notably
one of the earliest known ORS Gor
achieved quite a lot during his term and
successfully managed a number of magical
revolts he was also responsible for a
much-needed renovation and reinforcement
of Azkaban prison number eight
Maximilian crowd II Maximilian crowd II
was the 8th Minister for magic and
served 11 years from 1770 to 1781 crowd
II was a charismatic leader who was
instrumental in the mitigation of
pureblood extremist groups who were
intent on attacking muggles he
mysteriously died in office number 9
Porteous knatchbull Fortius knatchbull
was the ninth Minister for magic and
served eight years from 1781 to 1789
knatchbull was known for his
relationship with Lord Frederick north
the muggle Prime Minister of the time
North sought Naturals help with King
George thirds emerging mental
instability number 10 inchess
s Bert Osbert was the tenth Minister for
magic and served from 1789 to 1798 he
was not a very well rounded leader and
was far too influenced by pure Bloods of
wealth and status I'm sure Lucius would
have loved him number 11 Artemisia
Lufkin Artemisia Lucan was the eleventh
Minister for magic and served from 1798
to 1811 she was the first ever female
minister she's known for establishing
the Department of International magical
cooperation and lobbied heavily for a
Quidditch World Cup hosted in Britain
number 12
drogon stump Grogan stump was the 12th
minister for magic and served eight
years from 1811
18:19 stump is known for establishing
the Department of Magical games and
sports the inspiration for this stemmed
from his love for Quidditch number 13
Josefina Flint Josefina Flint was the
thirteenth Minister for magic and served
eight years from 1819 to 1827 she was
the second ever female minister she was
not particularly popular or progressive
as she was not fond of muggles number
fourteen auto line Gamble auto line
gamble was the 14th Minister for magic
and served from 1827 to 1835 gamble was
known for the establishment of
committees investigating muggle
brainpower
number 15 Rudolph is Lestrange Rodolfo's
Lestrange is the ancestor of the
Rodolfo's Lestrange that you're probably
thinking of he was the 15th Minister for
magic and served from 1835 to 1841 he
attempted to shut down the Department of
mysteries and eventually resigned due to
health concerns some speculate that it
was purely because he had trouble
handling the position number 16
Hortensia Miller foot or 10 zml afoot
was the 16th Minister for magic and
served eight years from 1841 to 1849
she was very active in the introduction
of legislation but not all of it was
good this led to her political downfall
number 17 Evangeline Orpington
Evangeline Orpington was the 18th
Minister for magic and served six years
from 1849 to 1855 interestingly enough
she was a good friend of Queen Victoria
the Queen never knew that orpington was
witch nebran
Priscilla de pon Priscilla de pon was
the 18th Minister for magic and served
only three years from 1855 to 1858 Dupin
hated the British prime minister at the
time Lord Palmerston and caused so much
trouble for him that she was forced to
resign number 19 Doug auld MacPhail Doug
old MacPhail was the 19th Minister for
magic and served 7 years from 1858 to
MacPhail was calm
reliable steady and just an all-around
good minister however he was voted out
at the maximum seven year election
interval number 20 Faris spout-hole
spavin Faris spout-hole spavin was the
20th Minister for magic and the longest
ever serving Minister can you guess how
long his term was an extraordinary and
write it in the comments what's your
guess
38 years and he served from 1865 to 1903
he survived an assassination attempt
which basically was just a kicking from
an upset center at age 147 it was gently
suggested by the wizened gamete that he
leave office number 21 the new SIA
Crickley was the 21st Minister for magic
and the second XOR to enter office she
served nine years from 1903 to 1912 she
died in a freak gardening accident that
was a Mandrake induced I guess she
wasn't wearing ear protection number 22
archer ever mond archer ever monde was
the 22nd minister for magic and served
11 years from 1912 to 1923 ever mons
time in office of course coincided with
the first muggle world war ever monde
passed legislation forbidding witches
wizards from getting involved but
thousands defied him number 23 Lorcan
macclare Lorcan McClaren was the 23rd
minister for magic and served only two
years from 1923 to 1925
macclare was a reserved and gifted
wizard but not a particularly effective
politician because of his nature he was
forced out of office because of his
eccentricities number 24
Hector folly Hector folly was the 24th
Minister for magic and served a long
14-year term from 1925 to 1939 folly was
mainly voted in because of his
personality which was a stark contrast
to the former minister McClair folly
however was not a particularly good
minister and did not handle the eminent
threat of Gellert Grindelwald very well
he was ousted from office
number 25 Leonard Spencer moon
Leonard Spencer moon was the 25th
Minister for magic and served from 1939
to 1948 he was solid as far as ministers
go and really worked his way up through
the ranks in Wizarding government he had
a sound working relationship with muggle
Prime Minister Winston Churchill number
Wilhelmina tuft Wilhelmina tuft was the
26th Minister for magic from 1948 to
1959 she was a very positive leader who
oversaw the Wizarding World during a
time of peace she died in office from an
unknown to her alle hot C flavored fudge
allergy number 27 Ignatieff tuft egg
Nadia's tuft was the 27th Minister for
magic and served only three years from
1959 to 1962
Ignatieff talk over for his mother
Wilhelmina
after her untimely death tuft was forced
out of office after his highly
controversial proposition to institute a
Dementor breeding program could you
imagine that
number 28 Nobby leach Nobby leach was
the 28th Minister for magic and the
first that was a muggle born a positive
sign in the progression of Wizarding
government he served from 1962 to 1968
he left office after contracting a
mysterious illness number 29 Eugenia
Jenkins
Eugenia Jenkins was the 29th Minister
for magic and served 7 years from 1968
to 1975 during her time in office there
was a lot going on from pureblood riots
to squibs marches on top of that she had
to deal with the first rise of Lord
Voldemort she was ousted from office as
she was not up to the challenge of
handling all of these issues number 30
Harold minja Harold Minchin was the 30th
Minister for magic and served for five
years from 1975 to 1980
Harold tried his best to contain Lord
Voldemort rise to power but was
unsuccessful this resulted in him being
kicked out of office and the rest will
be read by Silas
number 31 Millicent Bagnold Millicent
Bagnold was the 31st Minister for magic
and served 10 years from 1980 to 1990
Bagnold was highly capable and served in
office at the same time that the Potters
were attacked by Lord Voldemort at
Godric's Hollow Bagnold left office with
closing remark I assert our inalienable
right to party
number 32 Cornelius fudge hopefully
we're getting into small familiar
territory here Cornelius fudge was the
32nd Minister for magic and served from
1990 to 1996 fudge had some questionable
behavior during his time in office the
most questionable being his persistent
denial of Voldemort's return this denial
cost fudge his job
number 33 Rufus Scrimgeour Rufus
Scrimgeour was the 33rd minister for
magic and so from 1996 to 1997 he was
the third X or a to gain office and
faced an unfortunate death the hands of
Lord Voldemort number 34 pius thicknesse
pice thickness was the 34th Minister for
magic and served from 1997 to 1998 pices
term was for the most part omitted from
the records as he was under the Imperius
curse for the duration of his time in
office Kingsley Shacklebolt was the 35th
Minister for magic and served from 1998
to 2019 he's known for overseeing the
capture and containment of Death Eaters
and Voldemort supporters after the Dark
Lord's defeat Shacklebolt was initially
named caretaker minister but was
properly elected after all of his
successes number 36 Hermione Granger in
Hermione took over Shacklebolt and
assumed the role of Minister for magic
and that should cover about all of the
ministers what's interesting about
reviewing them is that we can see that
they for the most part got more and more
progressive over time some of the
original ministers were highly
intolerant of muggles and even based
their campaigns around that his taste
for the muggle world
fast forward to 1962 and a muggle-born
Nobby leach
took office
anyway that's it for this video which
ministers resonate most with you guys
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're always
sorry
[Music]